Alzheimer's disease is a progressive  neurodegenerative disorder that affects  the memory the signs and symptoms of  Alzheimer's can be remembered by five  A's where a means Amnesia loss of memory  anomia where you can't remember names  apraxia where you misuse a object  because you fail to recognize it  agnosia which means you cannot remember  familiar object and ephesia that means  difficulty in speech  pathological Hallmarks include amyloid  pluck and neurofibrillary tangles  the brain gets degenerated and it  shrinks moral of the story there are  death of the neurons that's why it's a  neurodegenerative disease the causes  could be genetic as well as sporadic  there is currently no treatment but  there are certain medications which can  improvise cognition  watch the full video for more